[Music]
here's your money briefing for Wednesday
May 17th I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
ozempic and similar drugs that have hit
the market in recent years may be able
to promise to help people lose weight
but insurers are often reluctant to
cover the cost of drugs that can list as
900 or more per month wsj reporter Anna
wilda Matthews joins us to discuss the
best ways to get your health plan to pay
for your prescription so Anna how do
these medications work and who are they
geared toward well ozempic isn't a
category of drugs that work by mimicking
the effects of a naturally occurring gut
hormone which is called for short glp-1
glp-1 drugs contribute to weight loss by
suppressing appetite and making you feel
full sooner when you eat ozempic and
munjaro are both geared toward people
with type 2 diabetes the FDA has
approved them for that use what Govi is
explicitly approved by the FDA for
weight loss for treating obesity
although the labeling on the drug
actually indicates that it's not just
for a person who maybe wants to lose a
few pounds it's really for people who
are in the category the clinical
category of obesity which means they
have a BMI of 30 or more or they can
have a BMI of 27 or more and then also
have a related health condition such as
high blood pressure so these drugs are
geared toward people with weight
problems for different reasons well so
specifically munjaro and ozempec are
approved treat diabetes they are not
approved to treat obesity so they are
really to help with diabetes with blood
sugar issues with Govi although it has
the identical active ingredient to
ozempic is explicitly approved for
weight loss what steps would someone
take to start treatment with these
medications well the first thing is is
obviously to see a doctor these are
prescription medications and people
can't just you know go to the drugstore
and pick them up and it is also true
that these medications can have a
significant side effects and we are told
by by The Physicians we interviewed for
the story it is important to be under
the care of a physician both when you
seek to get the drug and once you're on
it if your doctor does agree that one of
these drugs is a good fit for you that
you could benefit typically then there's
a process that you and your doctor will
have to go through seeking approval from
your insurance company that's not always
the case but it is increasingly and
often the case now on social media and
on the TV commercials the Splashy
headline is that these drugs can help
people lose weight why has it been such
a challenge for insurers to cover weight
loss drugs and programs in the past well
it is true that a lot of employers and a
lot of insurance plans don't cover drugs
explicitly for weight loss some do but
many don't in the past it has sometimes
been considered and I will put air
quotes around this a lifestyle or again
air quotes cosmetic issue that thinking
is definitely evolving in the medical
establishment Physicians often now
consider obesity not again quote
lifestyle issue but really a health
issue and a medical condition that needs
to be treated but again in the past a
lot of insurance plans haven't treated
weight loss drugs as something that was
vital to cover now if a doctor
prescribes the drugs is that the green
light needed for an insurer to cover the
cost it's often not the only green light
so if a physician prescribes one of
these drugs again typically there's a
process that is kicked off The Physician
will also often have to apply for
authorization for the drug to be covered
by the insurance plan often called prior
authorization so there may be a form
that the physician has to fill out or
perhaps a letter that they might have to
write
typically the health plan is looking for
evidence that proves that you really do
need the drug if you have type 2
diabetes and you're seeking access to
ozempic umunjaro you may have to show
first of all that you do have diabetes
and then in some cases they might want
evidence that you have already
previously tried a different drug for
diabetes and perhaps not gotten the
results that you were hoping for if you
don't have diabetes you probably would
be seeking with Govi because often
they're not going to give you the
diabetes medications if you don't have
diabetes and in that case they'd be
looking for things like whether you meet
the conditions that are spelled out in
the label of wagovi so again that would
typically be having a BMI of 30 or
higher or a BMI of 27 or higher along
with a related health condition such as
high blood pressure in addition there
sometimes looking for other things like
you've tried other efforts at Weight
Loss often through a structured program
and if a health plan does provide
coverage of ozembic wigovi or a similar
drug does that mean the patient is clear
of any out-of-pocket costs it depends on
the health plan as we all know that any
of us who've had more than one Health
Plan knows that can be completely
variable how much you have to pay out of
pocket for the same treatment depending
on what employer you're with or what
insurance plan you have but it can vary
it can be at just a flat cone payment
like we often experience for drugs but
these are pricey drugs and employers are
leery of the cost both of the drugs for
each patient and the number of patients
who potentially could be eligible for
them at some point so we did hear that
anecdotally that some employers are
starting to ratchet up the out-of-pocket
cost for patients who are getting
coverage for these drugs so instead of
perhaps a flat copay a plan might ask
you to pay a co-insurance which means a
percentage of the cost of the
prescription Ana this seems like a new
wave of drugs to address different ways
that people put on substantial amounts
of weight are we at a point now that
insurers are going to have to maybe
change their ways well it's maybe too
soon to tell one key thing to keep in
mind is it's not just insurers it's
often employers so depending on the size
of the employer most large employers for
sure are self-insured which means they
do decide they'll decide what what they
cover and what they don't there are not
federal regulations requiring that
weight loss drugs be covered so that
gives flexibility we did hear that
employees who are seeking these drugs
and feel that they they really need them
and whose Physicians feel they really
need them some do appeal to their and
their employers and insurers saying you
know I really need this and you need to
cover it they ask for either a change in
policy or for an exception for them and
this can work although it's not clear
how often it does but over time it seems
possible that more and more employers
will see pressure from employees seeking
access to these drugs and will again
come under sort of some pressure from
their own workers to change policies
when they when they don't cover them
that's Wall Street Journal reporter Anna
wilda Matthews and that's your money
briefing I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
[Music]
foreign